[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to HBO have just dropped their
first official trailer for Watchmen and
there's a lot to unpack from it
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the trailer as well as what it
signifies down the line this is full
spoilers ahead so if you don't want to
have anything roon for yourself then I
highly suggest that you turn off now
without the way.you huge thank you for
clicking this video I hope you enjoy it
now sit back relax let's watch the
trailer and get into my breakdown we are
no 1 we are everyone and we are
invisible we convinced ourselves that
they were gone but they were just
hibernating
they came for everybody oh please
obviously I guess we have ourselves
reckoning
[Music]
what are you two talking about oh
nothing just the end of the world okay
so the first big thing to take from the
trailer is that Rorschach's Journal has
clearly made it into mass circulation
with his death now sparking an uprising
and vigilantes the people have been
shaken out of their apathy and it seems
that the course that Ozymandias set the
world on in terms of salvation will be
brought down because of this with the
Doomsday Clock now taking once more
speaking of Doomsday Clock thankfully
the TV show will not be tying in to that
comic book at all and the world seems
like it's straying away heavily from it
which in my opinion is a good thing
anyway in order to combat this uprising
the police force have had it on their
home masks as they will no doubt be
unsure of exactly who is a vigilante and
who isn't this mirrors the original
niteowl who was a police officer but
wore a mask in order to fight the mob
who then retaliated by wearing their own
masks and this Escalade in into heroes
vs. villains
the Rorschach's are now taking down the
police because they view them as anti
freedom and liberty and realized that
society is now based on the lie that
Ozzy mondai is told in the graphic novel
that killed millions in order to divert
war we also get a flash of a carnival
with hundreds dead which could be a
callback to the dead that were killed in
the psychic attack at the end of the
graphic novel what's even dies to see
meditating and there's also a flash of a
pirate flag which is of course a
reference to the black freighter we then
see a mass that is mirrored and this
clearly signifies a reflection on
society that has pushed the world to the
point that at once again needs
vigilantes I can see this guy being the
villain and he's probably gonna
incorporate both the chaos and order
that the two sides are trying to enforce
and basically tear everything down we
end with a sheriff staying that he's
talking about the end of the world and
to me this signifies that the
Rorschach's will slowly begin tearing
down everything around them in order to
start again the two sides are clearly
going to war and I can't wait to see how
this pans out in the future Watchmen
looks incredible and it will no doubt
revitalize the property but many so and
hoping to see a huge resurgence
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the trailer and if I missed anything
out there make sure you comment bye
you know I currently do a podcast called
watching the Watchmen which breaks down
each issue of the graphic novel page by
page so if you interested in seeing a
full long-form analysis on the work make
sure you check it out at the end of this
video this is a channel for people who
are super into superheroes so if that's
the kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]